un cortège emporte Daniela et Marcello
vers leur union
[Musique]
un cortège qui selon les lois italienne
devrait être interdits une authentique
jeep des troupes de Romel escortés par
des side-cars du Troisième Reich ce que
le 20e siècle a inventé de plus
monstrueux utilisé pour célébrer l'amour
[Musique]
ici famille et ami ne sont pas des
fascistes juste quelques bourgeois venu
faire la fête
la guerre et l'amour ça va ensemble
parfois non
le fait que ce soit une jeep du
Troisième Reich avec des croix gammées
ça ne vous gêne pas
le mal
vous savez quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir interpréter
c'est très original on devrait tout
avoir la chance de se marier sur une
voiture comme ça
[Musique]
en Italie mais aussi en Allemagne en
France en Suède en Hongrie dans presque
toute l'Europe les références au nazisme
se banalisent et l'extrême droite
nationale populiste reprend du pouvoir
en Suède pendant que certains
groupusculas assassinent d'autres
Parlement
[Musique]
en Allemagne il rêve de bâtir une
société parallèle
en Italie il partage déjà le pouvoir
[Musique]
en Hongrie il marche au pas dans les
rues de la capitale
partout la droite radicale confinée au
cave et aux arrières salle depuis la fin
de la guerre fait un retour en force
[Musique]
centre-ville de Nice une marche aux
flambeau se prépare drapeau rouge et
noir ce sont les jeunes du Bloc
Identitaire un mouvement d'extrême
droite radical qui organise la marche
une marche en l'honneur de Catherine
segural la Jeanne d'Arc niçoise qui
boutta les Turcs de la ville au 15ème
siècle avec les fritements du Front
national la droite radicale qui reste
très minoritaire en France a perdu son
élément fédérateur
désormais elle tente de se restructurer
le Bloc identitaire est en passe d'y
arriver aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 150
à traverser la ville sous le contrôle de
Philippe Vardon le patron des identités
niçois
voir dans le défilé comme une énorme
majorité de jeunes donc voilà c'est
important pour nous de montrer que c'est
justement les nouvelles générations qui
ont le plus conscience de leur identité
qui sont présents pour pour honorer
notre plus longue tradition
Philippe Vardon ancien élève de Sciences
Po condamné à 50000 euros d'amende 8
mois de prison avec sursis et 2 ans de
privation de droits civiques pour
rédaction de tracts haineux et
reconstitution de ligue 10 foot
le Bloc Identitaire s'est construit sur
les cendres d'unités radicales un parti
interdit à la suite de l'attentat raté
contre Jacques Chirac le 14 juillet 2002
l'auteur du coup de feu contre le
président de la République était un
sympathisant d'une interradicale
aujourd'hui ces héritiers marchent au
flambeau au cœur de Nice dans
l'indifférence quasi générale
[Musique]
des extrêmes comme ça dans les rues et
que les gens regardent en prenant sa
super et en public
moi ça me fait penser au Ku Klux Klan
ça m'inquiète un petit peu
pardon et ses copains se sont présentés
pour la première fois aux dernières
élections municipales résultat près de
5% un score qui les place juste derrière
les grands partis aujourd'hui en guise
de discours Vardon sélectionne les vers
les plus virulents d'un poème de
l'époque dédié à l'agenda local
la voyez-vous saisir les temps d'arrêt
et foulées sous ses pieds sanglant et
déchirés l'audio croissant du Prophète
plonger et replonger au sein de
l'étranger noble femme se faire qui
venait nous venger et nous sauver de la
conquête
[Applaudissements]
non
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas entendu le
message les Identitaires se répandent
désormais sur le net
à l'aide de militants bénévoles formés
aux nouvelles technologies ils ont fondé
leur propre agence de presse d'avocation
a créé des alternatives à créer des
contre-pouvoirs effectivement créer une
agence de presse dans un monde de
communication dans un monde de
l'Internet où tout le monde peut avoir
aujourd'hui immédiatement accès aux
informations s'il veut bien les sonner à
peine de les chercher c'est
effectivement important je pense d'avoir
une agence de presse alternative comme
nouveau presse
un site moderne à l'apparence classique
presque professionnelle mais sur le fond
les articles enchaînent les allusions
racistes et xénophobes ici tout est fait
pour brouiller les pistes et visiblement
ça marche le site enregistre plus de 100
000 visiteurs par mois
fort de ce succès le lancement d'une
radio locale et d'un quotidien Niçois
sont prévus pour bientôt
mais pour faire passer ces idées nous
découvrons que le Bloc Identitaire a mis
au point une autre stratégie une méthode
bien plus sournoise l'infiltration
politique
pendant la manif à l'aide d'une caméra
cachée nous avons suivi André un
militant de la première il est au cœur
de cette stratégie d'infiltration
souhaitée par l'extrême droite André et
devenu une taupe au sein de l'UMP
ilage
de 300 mètres
joint par téléphone le maire de Cannes
Bernard brochant n'a pas souhaité réagir
ça va bien
ça va tranquillement on reprend au
quotidien wardon et ses copains jouent
aux politiciens bon temps tractage
meeting activité sociale mais surtout il
s'internationalise pour son meeting de
rentrée Vardon reçoit un soutien de
poids Mario borgettiu un des ponts de la
Ligue du Nord le grand parti populiste
italien avec 3 millions d'électeurs il
est la troisième force politique dans
son pays
de mettre dans la couverture de notre
revue la croix celtique parce que c'est
les symboles de notre addition quelqu'un
il dit que ce symbole fasciste je m'en
fous c'est c'est pas vrai
Mario borgettio ancien sous secrétaire
d'État italien à la justice et député
européen il a été condamné à 400 euros
d'amende pour violence sur vendeur
clandestin et à deux mois et 20 jours de
prison pour incendie d'un abri de SDF
étrangers
dans l'Europe de l'extrême droite
borgetzio est un modèle lui et son parti
incarne la preuve que le néophysisme
peut retrouver sa place sur le Vieux
Continent sur les 21 ministres de
l'actuel gouvernement Berlusconi 4 sont
de la Ligue du Nord le parti de Monsieur
Borghezio
il faut libérer nos gens il faut
retrouver l'engagement la force
l'enthousiasme de gagner les batailles
on commence dans le petit et on arrive
on arrive là où nous devons arriver
parce que nous sommes le reste de
commentaires nous sommes pas seuls
patrons nous sommes maître chez nous
c'est notre lutte ce nom de voir maître
chelou liberté
[Applaudissements]
après avoir chauffé la salle borgezio va
maintenant donner ses conseils aux
militants habituellement aucun
journaliste ne devrait entendre ce qui
va se dire mais là notre caméra tournait
C
[Musique]
pour les Italiens
de de d'être de n'être pas immédiatement
pensé comme fasciste nostalgie mais
comme une nouvelle mouvance
pénétrer partout où vous le pouvez et
mentez pour faire oublier que vous êtes
des fascistes la caméra est repérée on
en apprendra pas plus
nous poursuivons notre enquête dans le
pays où les groupuscules à l'idéologie
néonazis sont le mieux structurés la
Suède ici on trouve plus de 30 groupes
muscules ultra-radicaux politiquement
organisés le plus connu d'entre eux le
NSF NATIONAL socialistique France il
réunit des jeunes de 16 à 30 ans qui
défendent ouvertement l'idée d'une race
blanche supérieure le White Power
[Applaudissements]
les parties établissent des conséquences
de leur trahison envers le peuple
suédois
il y aura des sévices terribles comme
des viols collectifs des braquages des
meurtres contre les Suédois commis par
ses étrangers
c'est le futur de vos enfants qui est en
jeu car avec le gouvernement actuel la
Suède n'a pas d'avenir
aujourd'hui ces organisations néo-nazis
se multiplient dans le pays d'après les
autorités suédoises 17 nouveaux groupes
se sont créés ces deux dernières années
derrière ces adolescents rebelles et
leur meeting à l'apparence folklorique
se cache en réalité des jeunes très
violents
les journaux regorgent de leur crime de
haine comme celui d'un cure de
sauvagement attaqué à coups de couteau
ou le meurtre d'un handicapé
deux sympathisants nazis d'un groupe
muscul appelé le SMS ont filmé la
torture qu'ils ont infligé à cet homme
de 55 ans avant de le tuer
nourrit au combat de rue et à
l'ultra-violence les militants néonazis
cellules leur appartenance à leur groupe
par des serments comme pour des sectes
il est très difficile d'en sortir
Seb on paye le prix aujourd'hui ces
anciens camarades ont lancé un avis de
recherche contre lui depuis qu'il a
décidé de tout laisser tomber
attention aux traîtres il faut couper
tous les contacts avec lui le dénoncer
et le traité comme le traître qu'il est
les menaces de représailles sont à peine
voilées Seb vite aujourd'hui cachées
coupées du monde même la police
ignore ce qu'il est devenu
nous avons retrouvé un autre repentiste
Stéphane lucenen cet ancien chef
régional du NSF a fini par accepter de
nous parler
depuis qu'il a quitté le NSF il y a un
an il a été plusieurs fois tabassé par
ses anciens amis
j'ai peur qu'après m'avoir tabassé son
collègue
c'est à l'âge de 13 ans que Stéphane a
rejoint pour la première fois un groupe
néo-nazi entraîné par des copains
poussés par la violence à l'époque qu'il
s'est senti fort
il ne fallait pas aimer les juifs et les
sionistes et le système démocratique
qu'il est représenté
des images que je trouvais cool de
bagarre entre flic et nazis c'était ce
qui m'attirait beaucoup à ce moment-là
[Applaudissements]
même si pendant longtemps mon cœur
battait pour ce style de vie
au bout d'un moment je ne pouvais plus
assumer nos histoires de pureté et de
biologie raciale
parmi ces groupuscules de la haine il y
en a un qui a fait SAMU né en 88 de la
fusion de plusieurs groupes radicaux
dont certains avaient collaboré avec le
Troisième Reich le SD le parti des
Démocrates suédois n'a cessé depuis de
nettoyer son image plus propre ils ont
même été jusqu'à transformer leur logo
la flamme symbole traditionnelle de
l'extrême droite a été remplacée par une
fleur bleue
une stratégie payante aujourd'hui dans
certaines villes le SD dépasse les 20%
et il compte des représentants dans la
moitié des conseils municipaux du pays
plus jamais vu depuis la fin de la
guerre et cela pourrait empirer avec 18%
de sa population d'origine étrangère la
Suède et le pays d'Europe qui accueille
le plus grand nombre d'immigrés un
argument de taille pour l'extrême droite
depuis 1995 le magazine expo track 116
l'extrême droite suédoise créée par
Steve Larson pilier de l'antifascisme
européen et auteur du best-seller
Millenium à sa mort Daniel Poulard a
repris le flambeau il écrit actuellement
un livre sur le SD
au niveau des dirigeants du parti il n'y
a plus aucun contact avec les néo-nazies
car les leaders du SD n'ont pas intérêt
à voir deux liens avec eux il n'en va
pas de même pour les militants de base
pour eux la différence est minime entre
le SD et les néo-nazis
malgré l'effort de ces dirigeants le SD
entretient concrètement des liens avec
cette base radicale exploit mener
l'enquête
le dernier exemple de lien que nous
avons pu démontrer entre le SD et les
non-nazis et celui de 6 élus locaux du
SD que nous avons identifié et qui
sponsorise des groupes nazis violents
en 2007 Goran la grotte s’élimunicipale
a donné à 21 reprises de l'argent au SMR
le groupe huskule le plus violent du
pays
Yann casberg a eu local à verser à deux
reprises de l'argent responsable d'un
site néonazis Karine fenson et lui
régional a donné du matériel à NF pour
réaliser leur tracts livres de
propagande pour l'instant le montant des
versements reste secret et ses élus
refusent de répondre à la presse
aujourd'hui les Suédois s'inquiètent et
la mobilisation s'organise
pour empêcher le SD de répondre son
message des contre manifestations ultra
bruyantes se mettent en place un peu
partout
[Musique]
pourtant Mathias Carlson responsable
local du SD et serein les derniers
sondages montrent que son parti entrera
au Parlement dès les prochaines
élections
notre objectif immédiat c'est d'entrer
au Parlement et ceux dès les prochaines
élections en 2010 mais un moyen et long
terme notre but c'est bien sûr de
changer la politique et la société
suédoise
nous voulons revenir au passé cette
société fonctionnait beaucoup mieux dans
les années
50-60 et 70
pour le moment les Suédois refusent de
donner les clés du pays au SD mais
combien de temps tiendront-ils face à
l'irrésistible montée de Carlson et de
ses amis
si en Suède la droite traditionnelle
refuse les alliances avec l'extrême
droite en Italie elle participe déjà au
pouvoir
Véron dans le nord de l'Italie la ville
de Roméo et Juliette est aujourd'hui
l'un des fièvres de la Ligue du Nord un
parti xénophobe assistée populiste
Flavio Tosi a remporté la mairie avec
62% des voix
les véronés demandent que leur ville
soit en ordre qu'elle soit propre sur et
qu'elle soit administrées en faisant
attention aux vrais problèmes de la
population c'est ce qui a été fait
depuis mon arrivée
ces mesures phares militariser la ville
et placées des interdits à tout va entre
autres contre la prostitution les
immigrés clandestins ou les SDF sa
grande fierté avoir chassé les rhums de
la ville à coup de pelleteuse
dans sa municipalité Flavio Tosi
entretient des liens étroits avec les
fascistes son principal conseiller André
amélioranzi est un ancien skinhead
on les voit ici en décembre 2016 à la
tête d'un défilé organisé par les
groupes fascistes il protestent contre
les magistrats locaux qui selon eux s'en
prennent de manière injuste à l'extrême
droite
conseiller municipal de l'opposition de
gauche s'inquiète de cette dérive
sa ville et le laboratoire politique de
la Nouvelle Droite qui s'infiltre dans
toute l'Italie
cette expérience
est en train de se consolider au niveau
national avec le gouvernement Berlusconi
en effet depuis le 13 avril 2008 pour sa
troisième victoire Silvio Berlusconi a
noué des alliances jamais osé jusqu'ici
désormais il collabore avec la petite
fille du doute chez Alexandra moussolini
et d'autres figures infréquentables du
néo fascisme italien
6 d'entre elles sont d'ailleurs rentrés
au Parlement parmi lesquels deux anciens
membres du mouvement Ultra radical car
sa position
mais Berlusconi va plus loin il minimise
la répression politique sous le régime
fasciste
Mussolini n'a jamais tué personne il
s'est contenté d'envoyer des gens en
vacances
en Italie le tabou lui fascisme est
tombé dorénavant lors des meetings
certains militants n'hésitent plus à
acclamer berlosconi comme le duché
pour la droite les victoires
s'enchaînent 15 jours après le retour de
Berlusconi au pouvoir un membre de sa
coalition Jania lemano gagne la mairie
de Rome la goshitienne et laminé pour la
première fois depuis la chute du régime
fasciste en 43 elle perd la capitale et
des saluts fascistes accueillent le
nouveau maire
Rome change et je veux changer avec Rome
je suis contente car finalement je pense
que quand un clandestin se fera arrêter
en ville il sera expulsé
immigrés Johnny a le mano a gagné avec
53% des voix
[Musique]
nous allons apporter un changement
profond en commençant par la sécurité la
sécurité le travail et le social seront
mes trois mots d'ordre pour commencer à
administrer cette ville
djanielle et mano maire de Rome il a été
ministre de l'Agriculture de Berlusconi
ancien secrétaire national des jeunesses
du MSI le parti néo-fasciste aujourd'hui
dissout Alemano a été arrêté à plusieurs
reprises pour violence de rue sans
jamais être condamné
[Musique]
pour bien comprendre le personnage il
faut s'intéresser à son entourage
pendant les années de plomb l'Italie
était en proie à une véritable guerre
civile entre terroristes d'extrême
droite et d'extrême gauche en vingt ans
plus de 2000 blessés et 380 morts au
sommet de cette violence l'attentat de
la gare de Bologne le 2 août 1980
l'extrême droite italienne réalise l'une
des plus importantes attaques
terroristes que l'Europe est connue
85 morts et plus de 200 blessés à cette
époque gianniya et mano était proche des
fascistes violents il admirait pépé
Dimitri une des figures phares des
années de plomb un leader de l'extrême
rat radical plus tard Dimitri deviendra
son conseiller personnel
en 2006 il se tue dans un accident de
voiture ces funérailles sont l'occasion
de retrouvailles pour toute la droite
fasciste qui lui rend hommage en
première ligne en train de porter le
cercueil ganya et mano l'actuel maire de
Rome cette photo prise par un ami du
défunt n'avait jamais été diffusé
[Musique]
devant lui
gabrielafi l'intellectuel des fascistes
Romains condamnés pour appartenance à un
groupe terroriste de retour en Italie
après 18 ans d'exil en France
Rome une station de métro désaffectée
derrière ces grilles des militants
d'extrême droite se donnent
régulièrement rendez-vous pour la
première fois ils acceptent de laisser
rentrer une caméra ici la jeunesse
fasciste la plus militante se retrouve
pour organiser l'avenir autour
d'activités culturelles et de conférence
aujourd'hui leur invité d'honneur
Gabriel et adinnolphi l'ancien
terroriste et intellectuel du fascisme
grâce au ciel ou à qui vous voulez le
fascisme est en transformation
permanente aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'une
seule façon d'être fasciste c'est celle
d'être pragmatique
arrêtons de croire à toutes les
conneries qu'on nous raconte arrêtons de
prendre parti pour l'un ou pour l'autre
soyons les supporters de notre propre
avenir et construisons cet avenir sur la
base de notre passé
Gabriela écrivent un révisionniste
cofondateur de tertre sa position et une
organisation militariste ultra radicale
condamné pour association subversive et
appartenance à un groupe terroriste
exilé en France pendant 18 ans
la cristal pour assister à la conférence
du maître au milieu du nid de fasciste
un homme en chemise blanche
Stefano cortini ancien collaborateur du
maire de Rome qu'il verrait bien assis à
ses côtés
malheureusement pour le moment ça
fonctionne en empêche
mais j'en suis sûr il serait très
content d'être ici
dans ce squat dans notre monde les
militants de Casa Pound travaillent pour
remettre au goût du jour la culture et
la société fasciste
un idéal cadinolphin n'a jamais
abandonné
de plus aujourd'hui il offre des
propositions et des réponses très en
phase avec l'actualité bien mieux que ne
peuvent le faire les autres systèmes
politiques
je vous donne un exemple
ces jeunes ont fait une proposition de
loi qui permettrait à chaque famille
italienne de posséder une maison grâce à
une forme de crédit social
à travers des propositions de loi ou des
activités diverses les jeunes de Casa
Parme veulent diffuser leur message dans
toute la société italienne pour
gianlucaiano et le chef du mouvement le
meilleur moyen d'y arriver c'est de
toucher la jeunesse ce qu'ils font à
travers leur section lycéenne le
blockhaus to dentesco
dans les écoles de Rome et alentours
soit 25% des votes des élèves il est
évident que nous sommes en pleine
expansion car on dit tout au ce que plus
personne n'ose dire
il est 8h du matin devant le vice-conti
un des plus grands lycées de Rome les
jeunes du bloco studentes
comme il le font chaque matin devant une
dizaine d'écoles
sur 24 c'est toute ma vie tout le reste
vient après
et toi tu te sens fasciste oui je suis
fasciste
des fascistes qui traquent en pleine
ville et dans l'indifférence générale
ça ne te choque pas de voir des
fascistes dont on école non absolument
pas et les idées qu'il véhicule te
gênent non je ne partage pas pleinement
leurs idées mais elle ne me répugne pas
non plus c'est une tradition
Hugo Maria Tassinari spécialiste de
l'extrême droite nous explique pourquoi
depuis le retour de Berlusconi au
pouvoir ses militants peuvent tracter en
toute liberté
le précédent gouvernement Berlusconi en
2004 avec son ministre de la Justice à
dépénalisé le délit d'opinion
du fascisme ou que tu l'exaltes
mais sans aucun comportement violent
cela ne constitue plus un délit
et ceci a permis à des dizaines de
militants d'éviter des procès
des dépenses d'avocat des condamnations
pour éviter les procès la violence il
tente de la réserver à leur concert la
chanson qui cartonne en ce moment Chica
mandanza littéralement fouette avec ta
ceinture
[Musique]
ces jeux de militants qui en dehors des
concerts se donnent l'apparence de la
normalité nous en avons rencontré un il
a accepté de nous recevoir chez lui
Martine Navarro a 28 ans il milite
depuis qu'il a 13 ans
voici la photo de Mussolini et ça c'est
le drapeau de la République fasciste de
[__]
offert des amis pour mes 18 ans
je suis très lié effectivement à la
figure de Benito Mussolini pour moi ça a
été quelqu'un d'une loyauté et d'un
honneur exemplaire une personne qui a
fait du bien à sa patrie et à son peuple
Martine et chef de section pour force à
Nova un mouvement néo-fachiste né en 97
la famille l'église et la patrie sont
les mots clés de ces militants qui
voudraient entre autres interdire
l'avortement l'homosexualité et
l'immigration ce soir réunion en pleine
campagne aux portes de Rome organisées
par leur leader Roberto fioré il est
aujourd'hui député européen
en 1989 le mur du communisme est tombé
aujourd'hui en 2008 c'est la chute du
mur du capitalisme
le capitalisme
Roberto fioret député européen
cofondateur du mouvement d'extrême
droite tertre sa positionner il a été
condamné à 9 ans de prison pour
association subversive et bande armée
pour y échapper il s'est enfui 20 ans à
Londres est né rentré en Italie qu'à la
prescription de sa condamnation
[Musique]
nous nous rappellerons de ce moment
comme celui de la plus grande bataille
menée tous les jours pour sauver
l'Italie et l'Europe vive l'Italie vit
force à nous on va
le chef a chauffé les esprits un peu
partout des bracelets au moment où le
parti essaye de devenir fréquentable la
caméra gêne
Martine leur leader donne l'ordre
d'arrêter
[Musique]
pourtant il y a 2 ans fioré n'était pas
encore député européens et à cette
époque Martine et ses amis pouvaient
montrer leurs vrai visage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson culte de l'extrême droite
italienne a été écrite par Marcello De
Angelis il est aujourd'hui député au
Parlement dans la coalition de
Berlusconi c'est un ami personnel et
toujours très proche du maire de Rome
elle est pression
de mes états d'âme et de mes sentiments
je ne vois absolument aucune rupture
entre ce que je suis maintenant et ce
que j'ai été il y a 10 20 30 ou 40 ans
martellod et Angelis député italien
ancien membre du mouvement d'extrême
droite perte sa positionner il a été
condamné à 5 ans et 6 mois de réclusion
criminelle pour association subversive
et bande armée il s'est enfui pendant 9
ans à Londres avant de décider de
rentrer en Italie pour purger sa peine
[Musique]
malheureusement mon expérience
personnelle je l'ai seulement subie
j'ai subi des violences morales des
violences physiques des morts dans ma
famille des attentats
nation qui malgré les pressions il soit
on finit par rétablir qui était la
victime et qui était le bourreau même si
c'est avec 30 ans de retard
Marcello De Angelis Roberto fioré
Gabriela di Nolfi trois anciens amis
trois anciens membres d'un des
mouvements fascistes les plus radicaux
de la prière tout ce condamné
aujourd'hui proche du pouvoir ils sont
où ont tous été lié au maire de Rome
grâce à leur position actuelle ces
hommes peuvent inviter à leur meeting
des personnalités politiques de premier
plan
Roberto fioré reçoit cette année Gérard
curtzman un député du FPE l'extrême
droite autrichienne qui aux dernières
élections législatives à déstabiliser le
centre droit en remportant 18% des voix
il existe maintenant des formations de
droite dans presque toute l'Europe et
nous devons à l'image des autres grandes
formations politiques européennes nous
retrouvons par de la défontière pour
travailler ensemble
c'est pour cela que je suis ici pour
encourager nos amis italiens à
poursuivre la politique juste dans
laquelle ils se sont engagés
les Italiens se tourneront vers les
forces véritablement nationales et
sociales traditionnelles qui sont les
seuls à pouvoir représenter l'avenir et
l'espoir de l'Europe une photo et
l'aspect
parmi ces liens européens Roberto fioret
n'a jamais caché son admiration pour le
NPD le parti de l'extrême droite
allemande sur ses archives on le voit
aux côtés de leur chef Udo voice
le NPD le parti qui a permis au néonazis
de se réinstaller au cœur de la société
allemande
en Allemagne depuis 5 ans le NPD gagne
des mairies et a fait élire des députés
dans deux parlements régionaux
à deux heures de Berlin dans le
somptueux château de Spering se trouve
le Parlement régional
derrière ces murs le NPD compte 7
députés nous avons rendez-vous avec le
président de leur groupe parlementaire
et numéro 2 du parti Ludo Pastor
arrivé dans son bureau au mur un emblème
qui rappelle la croix gammée
la coupe de cheveux du secrétaire évoque
de vieux souvenirs et sur la tranche de
sa main droite le mot vérité un tatouage
qui marque son appartenance au plus
ultra parmi les néonazis convaincus
Ludo pasteur nous a reçu pendant deux
heures dans son bureau pour nous exposer
sa vision du monde le politicien est
habile il évite les dérapages trop
violents l'écume de l'antisémitisme et
les références trop directes à Hitler
mais en 2009 dans un parlement allemand
il n'hésite plus à tenir des propos
ouvertement racistes
nous aurions moins de guerre et moins de
problèmes en Europe si les gens ne se
mélangaient plus
nous devons donc aller vers la
ségrégation et non pas vers
l'intégration des peuples
nous dirigeants sont en train d'effacer
le déterminisme racial naturel qui nous
définir
d'abolir les lois naturelles qui nous
déterminent détermination
nous répéter qu'il n'y a pas de
différence entre les hommes que nous
sommes tous les mêmes c'est du lavage de
cerveau du totalitarisme
clairement le mélange des races c'est le
génocide des peuples racine
aujourd'hui pour répondre ces thèses le
NPD s'est mis à la recherche de
propriété à acheter un peu partout en
Allemagne nous en avons retrouvé une
dans la banlieue de Berlin un lieu
désaffecté barricadé et totalement isolé
trois bâtiments pouvant accueillir des
centaines de personnes que le NPD veut
t'acheter pour en faire un centre de
formation et même s'ils ne sont pas
encore propriétaires des lieux en
arrivant derrière le dernier bâtiment
nous découvrons qu'il l'occupe déjà à
l'abri des regards une place de garde
avec son mât son foyer et un symbole de
la mythologie germanique plantée sur un
bûcher nous avons montré ces images à
houlidjan responsable des archives sur
l'extrême rata allemande pour lui cela
ne fait aucun doute ce symbole est la
marque des mouvements pour la
résurrection du nazisme
il y a une jeunesse allemande qui fait
exactement ce que l'on sait des jeunes à
Hitleriennes ils ont entre 7 et 19 ans
ils vivent de manière passéiste avec des
valeurs qui sont celles du Troisième
Reich ils sont très engagés
politiquement
des témoins ont rapporté qu'ils
organisent des camps qui ressemblent à
des camps scouts romantiques mais qui
sont en réalité très militarisées il y a
même des formations au maniement des
armes
l'homme responsable de l'achat de ces
maisons siège lui aussi au château de
suarine Andreas
du NPD
nous appelons cela des zones nationales
libérées
pour la politique et la culture
car nous devons aussi développer des
lieux d'échange avec nos amis du reste
de l'Europe afin de montrer qui nous
sommes et de donner une nouvelle
impulsion à la politique nous devons
donc construire une société parallèle
en tant que nationaliste de droite les
valeurs de la société actuelle ne sont
pas les miennes et ce dont tous les
domaines en histoire mais aussi en
sociologie bien sûr en politique
pour pallier à cela des jeunes
nationalistes doivent recevoir une
formation alternative nous allons donc
créer des écoles pour les préparer à
prendre des responsabilités politiques
et à transmettre nos valeurs dans toute
la société
voilà ce que nous avons l'intention de
faire dans ces maisons
dont cette propriété de l'accompagne
berlinoise un corps de ferme composé de
5 bâtiments trois étapes et 20 hectares
de terrain le tout destiné à devenir une
auberge avec discothèque salle de
concert et bien sûr salle de conférence
la situation inquiète au plus haut
niveau au Parlement de Berlin une
commission vient de se créer pour
surveiller les activités de l'extrême
droite sous l'égide du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des services secrets
une étude publiée récemment par
l'Université de la psych montre que
15,4% des Allemands pensent qu'un fureur
dirigeant le pays avec fermeté serait
dans l'intérêt de tous
l'extrême droite est une de nos
principales priorités nous la plaçons
juste derrière le terrorisme islamique
l'État que le NPD veut établir est un
état incompatible avec la démocratie un
état qui se construit contre l'étranger
ils veulent renvoyer les immigrés qui
sont nés et qui ont grandi ici ils
veulent la ségrégation à l'école dès la
maternelle il se repose sur une
idéologie raciste et antisémite
à l'autre bout du pays à Cologne toute
l'extrême droite européenne c'est de mes
rendez-vous pour un grand meeting en
Islam plus de 1000 personnes sont
attendues les habitants de Cologne sont
révoltés
toute la ville se mobilise près de 20
000 personnes se réunissent pour dire
non au facho partout les militants
d'extrême droite sont bloqués et
repoussés violemment
les leaders de l'Europe extremiste eux
se retrouvent coincés sur un bateau
encadré par la police il tente
d'échapper aux attaques des
antifascistes
au bout de quatre heures tout le monde
débarque en première ligne Robert
Spiller français ancien Front national
fondateur de la Nouvelle droite
populaire à ses côtés Haral vilims qui
FPE l'extrême droite autrichienne ou
encore Philippe De Winter belge leader
du Vlams Belang l'extrême droite
flamande
[Musique]
ce qui se passe ici est incroyable je
croyais qu'en Allemagne depuis la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale il n'y avait
plus de dictatures mais c'est faux ils
ont remplacé une dictature de droite par
une dictature de gauche politiquement
correcte
dictator
il n'y a plus de démocratie
nous ne sommes pas des extrémistes nous
sommes des conservateurs qui en Autriche
en Italie en Allemagne ont des élus qui
représentent à travers toute l'Europe 15
à 20% de nos concitoyens
en tant que député européen Mario
borgettzio est le seul à bénéficier
d'une escort policière ils croient
rejoindre ses camarades mais arrivé sur
la place borgette Jo se retrouve face à
quelques journalistes et une poignée de
militants qui ont réussi à passer les
autres sont restés bloqués aucun
chauffeur de bus ni de taxi Nike
transporter
qui n'a pas peur de l'Islam de l'islam
du terrorisme islamique sur l'Europe qui
veut combattre défendre nos valeurs et
notre liberté
à quelques mètres de là les opposants
par milliers acclament le maire de
Cologne fritschrama
ce congrès mesdames et messieurs est en
réalité
une oeuvre politicienne qui se joue sur
le dos de nos concitoyens étrangers
Monsieur le Maire en première ligne sur
la lutte antifasciste se devait de
réagir dans sa municipalité l'extrême
droite a déjà 6 élus
ces hommes en chemise brune sont des
incendiaires des racistes déguisés en
bourgeois qui instrumentalise la peur de
l'autre pour exister politiquement mais
le brun ça se jette dans les toilettes
voici la sortie rentrer chez vous on ne
veut pas de vous ici
autre ambiance de l'autre côté du cordon
de police Borghezio toujours aussi seul
tente d'entretenir l'espoir
je suis orgueilleux de représenter la
Ligue du Nord pour l'indépendance de la
Padanie
un mouvement qui organise chaque semaine
partout cela est nécessaire
des manifestations contre les mosquées
islamistes
et contre le totalitarisme islamique
et je dédie cette intervention à la
mémoire
du micro est coupé Borghezio croit à une
panne de courant en réalité la police
vient d'interdire la manifestation le
risque de troubles à l'ordre public est
évoqué
ce jour-là à Cologne les antifascistes
ont gagné
[Musique]
Budapest le 25 octobre 2008
il faut que vos sections essayent
d'avancer au rythme du tambour dès que
vous arriverez sur la place vous devrez
tous marcher en cadence pied gauche boum
pied gauche c'est clair allez on y va
ces hommes font partie de la magie
regarda la gare hongroise une milice
d'extrême droite créée en 2007 par le
Parti nationaliste son but défendre une
Hongrie qui selon elle serait au bord du
gouffre et renverser le gouvernement
socialiste responsable de cet abîme
aujourd'hui
lagarda s'apprête à défiler au cœur de
la capitale pour introniser 400 nouveaux
membres
je tremble de la tête aux pieds
vous savez j'intègre la garde hongroise
aujourd'hui et c'est le dernier espoir
de la Hongrie
la jeune recrue qui nous parle ne
connaît pas encore les règles tu n'as
pas le droit de leur parler qu'est-ce
qui se passe vous avez peur que vos
gardes disent des choses embarrassantes
vous pouvez dire ça comme ça et parmi
les choses embarrassantes qu'il pourrait
dire vous avez peur qu'il dévoile le
caractère fasciste de votre milice
peut-être mais moi je n'ai rien à me
reprocher
le costume et le drapeau à bande rouge
et blanche rappelle celui des milices
prunasi des croix fléchés qui ont dominé
la Hongrie en 44 ce drapeau banni depuis
la fin de la guerre refait son
apparition un peu partout
ils sont plus de 1000 à débarquer sur la
place des héros de la nation la place la
plus importante de Budapest sous les
applaudissements du public et sans un
cri de protestation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un silence religieux leur chef
gaborent
recommencez à croire recommencer à
espérer retrouver le bonheur et
retrouver notre fierté
tout cela c'est grâce à vous la garde
que l'on y arrivera
vous êtes les derniers rayons d'espoir
de la nation hongroise
qui voudrait vivre dans un pays qui se
nomme Hongrie mais qui est entièrement
aux mains des étrangers
qui voudrait vivre dans un pays où des
Shimon Perez mettent leur nez dans
toutes nos affaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce salut qui envahit la place et le
salut traditionnel des nationalistes
radicaux
l'extrême droite hongroise est remontée
alors qu'avant la crise financière le
taux de chômage proche de 7% étaient en
baisse et que l'immigration y est la
plus faible d'Europe alors comment la
Hongrie ce bon élève de l'Union
européenne a-t-elle pu en arriver là
[Musique]
sociologue de premier plan Maria va
sarélie suit depuis plus de 10 ans les
dérives extrémistes de son pays
le plus grand problème en Hongrie c'est
que l'extrême droite est fortement
soutenue par l'élite politique et plus
particulièrement par le plus grand parti
de la droite traditionnelle le fidèles
ce soutien du fidèles et de son patron
Victor Orban même s'il n'est pas direct
n'en reste pas moins évident le fidèle a
intérêt à ce que l'extrême droite existe
et soit visible auprès de la population
ancien Premier ministre de 98 à 2002
Victor Orban dirige le fidèle le parti
du centre droit en 2002 après 4 ans à la
tête du pays il perd face à la gauche
port van et son parti décide alors de
radicaliser leur discours et de
s'appuyer sur l'extrême droite pour
retrouver le pouvoir une première depuis
la fin de la guerre
ancien conseiller personnel et biographe
de Victor Hormann Joseph Nice est retiré
de la vie politique avant la dérive
ultra populiste du fidèles d'ordinaire
discret il accepte pour nous de juger
son ancien patron
le fidèle est très tactique
très rusé dans sa manière de surfer sur
ses relations avec l'extrême droite son
discours est toujours très tendancieux
[Musique]
les thèmes de l'extrême droite de les
avoir rendu plus efficaces
il a su exploiter les idées nausées qui
restaient enfouies dans ce pays depuis
la fin de la guerre
23 octobre 2006 jour de fête nationale
Orban réclame la démission du
gouvernement avec l'aide de l'extrême
droite il fait descendre près de 200 000
personnes dans la rue très vite les
esprits se chauffaient la manifestation
d'érable dans une violence extrême
les émeutes mettent à mal le
gouvernement et Orban remonte dans les
sondages il comprend qu'il tient un bon
créneau un an plus tard le 23 octobre
2007 le même scénario se répète et la
ville s'enflamme à nouveau
23 octobre 2008 l'extrême droite est à
nouveau dans les rues de Budapest cette
année encore l'attention est vive à
chaque coin de rue la police fouille les
manifestants
dans la foule nous croisons des
militants de groupuscules radicaux
flamand et français qui sont venus
soutenir les extrémistes locaux Sacha
s'est mis en tenue de soirée une sorte
d'hommage à la gare hongroise
d'un point de vue historique ce qui se
passe ici est juste phénoménal j'espère
qu'en Flandre et aussi en France nous
pourrons avoir à nouveau de pareil
milice mais pour le moment les lois nous
en empêchent ce qui est une honte Sacha
vient de finir les études d'histoire il
se prépare à devenir prof en Belgique
autour de lui des skins et autres
militants extrémistes il est 23 heures
la baston n'a pas encore débuté et nos
jeunes loups commencent à avoir faim
quand on est nationaliste cela peut
parfois poser un problème
[Musique]
quel est le plus grand ennemi est-ce que
c'est le kebab ou le McDonald's
parce qu'il n'aime pas le kebab je
désapprouve totalement je préfère
beaucoup bien
vous avez bientôt moi j'aime bien les
Turcs
non plus
pas de sandwich pour nos fachos mais
surtout pas de bagarre
cette année pas la moindre effusion dans
les rues de la capitale hasard ou
coïncidence le fidèle avait décidé pour
la première fois de ne pas participer
aux manifestations après s'être appuyé
sur l'extrême droite pour revenir sur le
devant de la scène le fidèles désormais
certain de diriger le pays des 2010 a
décidé de prendre du recul avec les
chemises noires
mais le mal est fait même si l'extrême
droite radical ne totalisent que 1 à 2%
des voix lors des élections la garde
milice fasciste en uniforme fait
désormais partie du paysage dans la
société hongroise les idées de l'extrême
droite sont devenues acceptables
[Musique]
un petit village a une quarantaine de
kilomètres au sud de Budapest depuis la
rentrée de septembre le nouveau
directeur de la seule école primaire de
la région affiche ses sympathies pour le
nazisme
en 2005 Peter cocheras a mis le feu aux
poudres en diffusant une photo de lui en
uniformet 16 une photo prise lors d'une
sortie scolaire prof d'histoire dans un
lycée privé à l'époque il avait dû
démissionner trois ans plus tard il est
nommé directeur d'un établissement
public
devant l'école Le premier geste du
nouveau directeur la mise en place du
tout roule emblème des nationalistes
hongrois
que sera apprécie peu la présence de
notre caméra mais après une longue
négociation il finit par accepter de
nous parler de la photo
[Musique]
pour illustrer une page de notre
histoire
pour vous les faire en sorte que les
enfants puissent toucher les vrais
uniformes de l'époque
mieux que dans les musées où ils ne
peuvent pas accéder aux objets
vous savez pendant la guerre la Hongrie
s'est battue aux côtés de l'Allemagne
nazie et nous avons perdu cette guerre
aujourd'hui on s'en fiche de savoir
quelle nation était de quel côté dans
les combats mais sur le plan moral il
est grand temps d'admettre que les
vainqueurs ont autant de choses à se
reprocher que les perdants
Roosevelt autant coupable qui claire
désormais à tordage les enfants sont
encadrés par un directeur révisionniste
Sylvia maire d'une élève de l'école n'en
revient toujours pas
depuis l'arrivée de ce monsieur cocheras
dans l'école ils ont mis en place des
cours de danse folkloriques
l'apprentissage d'instrument
traditionnels hongrois et des champs
nationaux
que les cours de citar étaient plus
utiles que les cours de langue ou
d'informatique ça a été le coup de trop
on a retiré notre fille de l'école
pour le moment 4 enfants ont été retirés
de l'école
relooker populiste ou franchement
fasciste l'extrême droite s'est refait
une santé dans toute l'Europe depuis la
fin de la guerre ces idées n'ont jamais
été aussi présentes dans la société
aujourd'hui elle fait partie des
majorités au pouvoir dans 5 pays et elle
est à son plus haut niveau électoral
dans 18 pays d'Europe
l'hégémonie culturel de la gauche qui a
duré de 1945 à 1989 est terminée
[Applaudissements]
partager par des gaullistes et pas des
communistes chrétiens démocrates et des
socialistes par tout le monde c'est fini
c'est fini racine Michaud
sont brisés et pour toujours
petit à petit sans que l'on s'en
aperçoive l'Europe fasciste gagne
partout du terrain et se prépare un
avenir radieux
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait la même chose
en France
[Musique]